- [Instructor] Let's
say I want to multiply
3.1 or 3 1/10
times
times 2.4
which could also be
described as 2 4/10ths
so pause the video if you can do this
and once again, I'll give you a hint.
See if you can express these
as fractions.
So there's a couple ways you
can express it as a fraction.
You can express this as 3 1/10th
times
2 4/10ths
two,
let's get the same color,
2 4/10ths.
Now whenever you're multi
these are mixed numbers
right over here and
mixed numbers are not the super
straightforward to multiply,
it's easier if they were written as
what's often known as improper fractions
but essentially not as mixed numbers.
So three is the same thing as 30/10ths.
So 30/10ths plus 1/10th,
this is 31
10ths
times
two is the same thing as 20/10ths.
So 20/10ths plus four is 24/10ths.
over 10.
And hopefully this
makes sense too that 3.1
this three right over here,
this is
30/10ths
or I can write,
let me write 30/10ths
and that this is 1/10th.
So this total is going to be 31/10ths.
Likewise, this two
is 20/10ths
plus 4/10th because it's 24/10ths.
And now we can multiply.
So this is going to give us
our denominator's pretty straightforward.
10 times 10 is
and then 31 times 24, we can multiply
in the traditional way
that we're used to
multiplying two digit numbers.
31 times 24
is going to be equal to
four times one is four,
four times three is 12,
now we're gonna be multiplying
in the tenths place.
We're going to put a zero here.
So two times one is two.
We're really saying 20 times one is 20.
But you get the idea.
Two times one is two.
Two times three is
six.
Really 600, because it's 20 times 30.
But I'm just following the standard multi
the method for multiplication
then you add these.
And you're gonna get four
four
seven.
So when you multiply
these two things together,
in the numerator, you get 744
100ths.
Which can also be expressed as
this is the same thing as 700ths
or 700 100ths I should say,
plus 44/100ths
and 700/100ths,
that's just going to be equal to seven.
So this is seven
plus 44/100ths
which we could write as
.44
that's our seven and 44/100ths.
And we would be done.
And you might already be seeing a pattern.
If you just took 31 and
multiplied it by 24,
you get 744.
And notice,
I have one
and two digits behind the decimal point.
Notice I have one
And so think about
whether that always works.
Think about and why that might work.
If you just multiply the numbers
as if they didn't have decimals,
so you would've gotten 744
and you say, I got two
numbers behind the decimal,
so my product is going to have two numbers
behind the decimal,
why does that work?
Or does it always work?
And how does it relate to what we did here
which is converting these things to
improper fractions
and then multiplying it that way?